today on the matte wall show public
health experts are suggesting that we
should give out the vaccine based on
race
they're advocating openly for racial
eugenics in the way we distribute the
vaccine we'll talk about that today also
five headlines including
a major spike in cases in l.a county but
if the lockdowns work
why would this be happening in one of
the places in the country with the
strictest lockdown policies and in our
daily cancellation i will
respond to the people who are angry at
me for daring to suggest
as i did yesterday that it's not good to
be a prostitute
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
with more people shopping during the
holiday season this year online
it's more important than ever to uh to
take care of your online identity and to
protect yourself
you know some experts say that consumers
are at a higher risk of identity theft
as well as falling victim to deals that
are too good to be true and
sophisticated
phishing attacks during the holidays
which really makes a lot of sense
considering
you know what how you got your you're
buying things
your credit card information you're
spending a lot of time you're giving
your information probably to more
websites than you normally would at any
other time of the year
experts recommend checking your credit
school score not overspending
and limiting new retail credit cards and
also freezing your credit if needed even
after the holidays
um those are all things that you can do
but there's so much more and one of the
and the main thing you can do to protect
yourself is to get lifelock
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives
this holiday season you could miss
certain identity threats just by
monitoring your credit or your bank
statements
or even taking the the measures just uh
just described
lifelock though can take care of
everything lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats like your
social security number being for sale on
the dark web
if they detect your information has been
compromised then they can send you an
alert and if you do become
a victim of identity theft as so many
millions do every year
then they can help you restore your
identity um
one of their specialists can help you
restore that and they can take care of
that as well so it just gives you
it gives you protection on both ends of
this thing um and there's just no reason
not to do it look nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can help you feel warm and
protected this holiday season
save up to 25 off your first year just
go to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh
for 25 off well as kova vaccines are now
being distributed and administered it's
it's been i have to say
quite encouraging to see so many people
who derided trump for promising a
vaccine within the year actually hold
themselves accountable now and admit
they were wrong apologize to the
president
and thank him you know so many on the
left have done this and it's been
extremely
inspiring to see maybe there is hope for
national unity after all
i'm just kidding of course trump has
gotten precisely zero credit for falling
through on his promise
and so far as i can tell none of the
people who openly mocked him for saying
it would be out in a year
have admitted their error much less
apologized much less
thank the president for getting this
done instead um they're talking now
about forming commissions to prosecute
the trump administration
for failing to save even more lives and
we'll play that clip for you in the five
headline segment coming up but
as for the vaccine it's roll out um hit
a bit of a speed bump yesterday when a
nurse in chattanooga
received the shot and then immediately
went in front of cameras for a press
conference to talk about it
and things went a little bit off the
rails from there listen
we are in the covered unit so therefore
you know
my team will be getting first chances to
get the vaccine
and i know that um it's
really i'm sorry i'm feeling really
dizzy
oh i'm sorry
yeah so she passed out uh there on
camera after taking the vaccine
and this is exactly the opposite sort of
pr
they were hoping for and in fairness you
know it's not uncommon for people to
become
light-headed or to faint after getting a
shot i'm not i'm not a big fan of
needles myself i have to admit so
i can somewhat understand though to be
clear i've never fainted after one so
because that would be
unmanly but the point is that most
likely this nurse's reaction
doesn't tell us anything about the
vaccine itself yet the optics are not
good and there's no getting around that
the campaign then to push the vaccine on
us by bribe or threat or mandate will
only have to be
ramped up now to can't to compensate now
my own view
on the vaccine is not terribly bold or
interesting i've shared it before
but it's the only view that makes sense
to my mind and that is you know
i think if you want to get the vaccine
you should and if you don't want to get
it you shouldn't
and that's my position on all vaccines
and always has been
it's my position on this one personally
i probably
won't get it because my covert risk
level is extremely low
and besides i'm so far back in line by
by the time that it's available to me
it might be sort of a moot point by then
but people should be able to make their
own choices
and choice being the operative word here
a word used very often in political
discussions
though the people who define themselves
as pro-choice
often show that they have a very narrow
and limited idea of when and in what
circumstances
the pro-choice principle should apply
namely uh they apply it to
abortion prostitution and drug use and
not much else
so those are the only realms in which
they they are in favor of choice
the other key point about how the
vaccine is distributed and administered
aside from the point that it should only
be given to those who freely choose it
is that priority in its distribution
should be afforded to those who are most
vulnerable
this seems rather obvious and is a
position that shouldn't need to be
explained or defended
of course people most vulnerable should
be the ones to get it first but
we have to explain and defend it turns
out because many of our health experts
quote unquote
have other ideas there's an article in
new york times didn't get much attention
when it was published a week ago the
fact that it didn't get much attention i
think tells you something
but it features health experts who are
pushing what can only be described as a
form of racial eugenics in relation to
the vaccine
i'm not exaggerating listen to this this
is from the new york times
says with the chronovirus pandemic
surging and initial vaccine supply is
limited the united states faces a hard
choice
should the country's immunization
program focus in the early months on the
elderly and people with serious medical
conditions
who are dying of the virus at the
highest rates or on essential workers
an expansive category encompassing
americans who have borne the greatest
risk of
infection now by essential workers
it is meant um among other things fast
food fry cooks
and walmart cashiers and people in that
realm
many of whom are nothing against them
but many of them the point is are young
and are not in any serious risk from the
virus
that's precisely why these fast food and
retail establishment
establishments have been able to stay
open and you haven't often heard of the
employee roles of these
stores getting wiped out from the virus
you know
there really isn't anything to discuss
to discuss here or or there shouldn't be
of course we should not be prioritizing
a 17 year old kid working at burger king
over an elderly person who belongs to an
age bracket that's been that's borne by
far the brunt of coveted casualties
of course the elderly should come first
they're the ones
dying from the disease by and large
so the answer here is obvious but not to
the new york times
they continue and it gets worse from
here dr
peter uh zil agia let's call him
he says to me the issue of ethics is
very significant
very important for this country he's a
committee member and a pediatrics
professor at the university of
california los angeles
uh he said at the time and he said quote
it clearly favors the essential ethics
clearly favors the essential worker
group because of the high
proportion of minority low-income and
low-education workers
among the essential worker bracket
now wait a second why should essential
workers be favored
because there's a high proportion of
minorities
why should that factor into the equation
at all i mean who cares what race they
are what difference does that make
there are a lot of elderly black people
too last i checked
but who cares again either way are we
really going to decide
who gets to be saved based on their race
is that actually what's being proposed
here the answer is yes
yes it is that's what they're proposing
back to the article
uh mark lipsich an infectious disease
epidemiologist at harvard's t.h
chen school of public health argued that
teachers should not be included as
essential workers
if a central goal of the committee is to
reduce health inequities
he says teachers have middle class
salaries are very often white
and they have college degrees of course
they should be treated better
but they are not among the most
mistreated of workers
you know they aren't just white they're
very white they're they're in a late
stage of whiteness
the case is terminal for them but mark
says the goal is to reduce inequities
well no it isn't the goal is to reduce
infection and death from the virus
that has to be the goal of vaccine
because there are no vaccines for
inequities
but don't worry senior economist elise
gold
says that actually teachers maybe should
be prioritized
not for their own sake but because it
would be helpful to black and brown
people quote unquote
to help them she says here's the quote
from the article says elise gould
a senior economist at the economic
policy institute
disagreed teachers not only ensure that
children don't fall further behind in
their education she said but are also
critical to the workforce at large
quote when you talk about
disproportionate impact and you're
concerned about people getting back into
the labor force many are mothers and
they will have a harder time if their
children don't have a reliable pace to
go
and if you think generally about people
who have jobs where they can't telework
they are disproportionately black and
brown they'll have more of a challenge
when child care is an issue
okay so teachers might be saved because
they're useful to black people
but it gets even worse for the grand
finale
here's the final and most direct pitch
for eugenics that you get in this
article
harold schmidt an expert in ethics and
health policy at the university of
pennsylvania
said that it is reasonable to put
essential workers ahead of older adults
given their risks and that they are
disproportionately minorities
dr schmidt says older populations are
whiter
society is structured in a way that
enables them to live longer
instead of giving additional health
benefits to those who already had more
of them
we could start to level the playing
field a bit
yes level the playing field
level the playing field think about that
phrase
if you're wondering why people don't
trust health experts
look no further these are radical
ideologues
who put their warped ideas of racial
justice and equity
ah ahead of anything and everything else
how can we trust them here they are in
this article
hoping to level the playing field by
letting white people die
and yet we still will be lectured for
not trusting the experts
no of course we don't trust them there's
nothing to trust here
and this is their own doing this is
their decision to go in public
and say things like this when people
respond to that
logically by saying we can't listen to
these people you know that's that's not
our fault
that is their fault 100 now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
i want to tell you about the new sponsor
we have on the show that i'm very
excited about because
i i believe strongly in protecting
yourself and being able to protect your
family
and that's what they're all about over
at taser
tasers line of non-lethal
self-protection devices are small
lightweight enough to carry with you or
in your glove compartment or purse
they're also powerful uh very powerful
enough to incapacitate an attacker
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
giving you time to escape to safety and
send emergency dispatch to your gps
location
so they got both they've got both of
that um it's it's you're going to
incapacitate the attacker
but also it's going to alert um it's
going to alert emergency personnel
law enforcement and they're going to
show up and they'll be there as well and
they also have
laser-assisted targeting to protect
yourself and your family with taser's
line of smart
self-defense products and this is one of
those things when they when they told me
about this sponsor you know my first
question was
am i going to get am i going to get the
product and they said i was told yes i
am going to be receiving a taser myself
which i am um excited about it's it'll
be something great
uh for my wife you know this is a real
conversation i've had with my wife
very recently in fact just last week we
were talking about how she wanted to get
something like
this and now it's on the way and it
could be on the way to your house too
taser is available without a permit in
most u.s states
get the taser pulse plus or taser strike
light at taser.com
with promo code walsh you can say 15 off
now at taser.com promo code walsh it's
spelled t-a-s-e-r
dot com promo code walsh restrictions
apply see site for details
a report from uh abc7 says the icu
capacity in the 11 county southern
california region
has dropped to zero percent amid a
dramatic surge in coronavirus cases
according to officials on thursday
california hospitals are required to
report
the total number of all available
staffed icu beds each day regional icu
capacity is calculated by subtracting
neonatal and pediatric intensive care
beds
from the number of adult beds news of
the diminished icu capacity came as the
state announced the deaths
of 379 californians marking the highest
number of fatalities in one day
since the pandemic began and surpassing
the previous record set the previous day
it says the state reported another 52
000 new cases of the virus just 1400
cases less than what californians saw
the day prior
okay so there they are uh
setting records now we've got a life
lost every four minutes in a 24 hour
span is what they're saying
in the state of california they're
setting what they say anyway
what's being reported is that they're
setting records for covet deaths the
cove infection is going crazy
icus are full that's what they're
claiming
um well
california's also had the strictest
lockdowns
in the country or among the strictest
especially in southern california
especially in la county
it's one of the strictest places in the
whole country
and if you've been there at any point
during the pandemic which i have
uh many people this building have lived
there before it's
you know you don't see people walking
around without masks everybody's wearing
a mask
everybody's following the protocols
and yet the virus is doing what the
virus is going to do
which has been the contention of the
anti-lockdown set from the very
beginning
that you're not going to stop the virus
by telling everyone to hide in their
homes
it's not going to work you're not going
to be able to do it
um and on top of that you're keeping
people cooped up
in their homes with each other and
that's the primary way that the virus
spreads we're told
this this would seem to be evidence
that the lockdowns haven't been very
effective but we're not allowed to talk
about that
uh or acknowledge that no what this
means is that um
is that well you know it's not a we just
need to do more of what didn't work
we just need to do it to a higher degree
or we'll be told that no those
it's it wasn't a real lockdown yeah we
tried
fake lockdowns but not the that wasn't
the real thing
we still haven't tried the real
authentic lockdowns those are what works
uh number two yesterday on msnbc a
member of their talking head panel went
into great detail explaining
why should there why there should be uh
panels
after the trump administration to
prosecute the trump administration
uh because you know it's their fault
that all these people died from covid
here's uh here's what this lunatic had
to say
uh and also when you compare trump and
bush bush killed hundreds of thousands
of people
abroad you know brown and black people
in far away countries that we don't care
about
donald trump killed hundreds of
thousands of people who presided over
the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of people
preventable death here at home
in the united states of america and that
for me you know you talk about morally
abominable it's sociopathic
uh you mentioned earlier in the show the
four words that will be the epitaph is
we want more infections we want more
infected uh you know
what about who cares in those emails
that jumped out at me
this guy paul alexander writes if we
have more cases more people infected
more
more positive tests who cares and you
take who cares
you add it to donald trump's it is what
it is you add it to jared kushner's
that's their problem when people in new
york are dying this is sociopathic this
is not just morally or vulnerable
and i think people should be held to
account i think they should be
prosecuted
the people behind these preventable
deaths should be prosecuted when they
leave office on january 20th
yeah they're and they're this is they're
out for blood the left is out for blood
that's very clear uh they want they
it's not enough to win they want to
punish they want to punish
those who have opposed them for the last
four years and they're going to do it
too
especially especially if they take
control of the entire government well
the reason why these races down in
georgia are so important
they can control the entire government
they're going to do it
this is this is revenge they're looking
for meanwhile again
we've got a we've got a vaccine i mean
this is really it's
we're not taking any time to appreciate
it in fact you know it's kind of on both
sides because
the left doesn't want to appreciate the
fact that the vaccine came out so
quickly because
they have been proven wrong and they
don't want to give trump credit for
anything at all
and they're very let's be clear they're
very upset that this thing is coming out
while trump is in office they would much
prefer if it was another couple months
uh and people are dying in the meantime
they don't talk about being sociopathic
they don't care about that
they just don't want trump to get credit
for it so of course the left's not gonna
get him credit but then
on the right there's a lot of uh
skepticism about the vaccine and i'm not
saying that
all that skepticism is is off base but
uh
at the same time you know there is and
so he's not getting a lot of credit
there either
meanwhile this is this is an enormous
achievement
that is really not appreciated by hardly
anyone at all
number three um also yesterday john
berman on cnn
hit on an important point actually that
there's been a spike in
deaths among young people
over the past several months and even
though young people are not
very susceptible to um to
carnovirus still they've been dying at a
much higher rate than they have in the
past
only he of course reaches the wrong but
predictably wrong conclusion
listen the authors of it is dr rochelle
wolinski who will run the cdc starting
in a few weeks
which found that young people are dying
at higher rates over the last year than
they were
before it found that july appears to
have been the deadliest month among this
group in modern
american history over the past 20 years
an average of 11 000 young americans
died each july this number swelled to
more than
16 000. we're talking about people ages
25 to 44
5 000 more deaths in the month of july
than the previous average and the
implication is
is that it's largely because of
coronavirus
yeah uh so it's it's because of the
coronavirus that all these
young young people are dying now
although that's that's that's not what
the data
shows that's not that's not what's borne
out um
is i mean is look at look at look at the
data is that what we see
that all these young people are dying of
the coronavirus
he says well the implication you know
it's probably because of that
yeah that's not actually what you see
when you look at the numbers you don't
see
young people dying in mass dying in
droves from the coronavirus not at all
yet young people are dying at a higher
rate
why is that well it seems pretty clear
to everybody else you look at the
suicide spikes that have already been
reported
drug abuse isolation uh the
the deterioration of mental health
that's what's happening
these are young people just like
everybody else isolated
and if you have someone who already is
struggling with mental health problems
depression uh you know struggling with
addiction
and then you lock them in their home for
seven months
this is what happens it's not the
coronavirus it's the policies
once again as always number four
speaking of horrible policies
um the gothamist has a uh has a story
with a bunch of
photos of people dining outdoors and you
can find these on on social media as
well
dining outdoors in new york during the
snowstorm
that that hit the city you know below
freezing temperatures people are sitting
out in a snowstorm eating outside
because you can see some of the pictures
because because they can't go inside
and then here's the latest so already
they're being forced
to eat outside in a snowstorm below
freezing temperatures
now we have this from the new york post
it says
big apple eatery owners were thrown into
a panic
thursday night when the cuomo
administration dropped new rules that
barred patrons and outdoor spaces from
using their indoor bathrooms
now up until now at least if you had to
eat outside you could still walk inside
to use the bathroom
but not not anymore the initial guidance
released publicly by
a council to mayor bill de blasio stated
that customers are not allowed to enter
the inside
of one of these restaurants for any
reason while the guidance is in effect
to the dismay of some eatery owners the
guidance indicated that even the
bathrooms will be off limits
one of the questions on the document
says if my sla licensed establishment is
offering outdoor dining may i allow
customers to use the bathroom inside the
reply states
no customers may not enter the inside of
the establishment for any reason
okay yes this is this is good for public
health isn't it
this is the best thing we could do for
public health force people to eat
outside in the snow in below freezing
temperatures
and then bar access to sanitation
facilities
is it part of the thing we're supposed
to be washing our hands a lot now you
can't go inside and wash your hands
what if you have to use the bathroom now
you can have people running what in a
back alley behind the restaurant
just absolutely crazy and there's no
reason to do it there is no health-based
reason to do it
are there a lot of people getting
coronavirus as they walk to the bathroom
they walk across an arrest they're
walking across an empty restaurant
to the bathroom do we have any data at
all that indicates that
anyone has gotten sick from coronavirus
from doing that
of course not just uh completely
just p people in the future will look
back on this
and they they won't believe it there's
so much that's happening right now that
i think people in the future will not
believe they'll think that their history
books are lying to them which the
history books might lie to them and not
tell them about some of these things
number five joe exotic of tiger king
fame is suing the department of justice
for rejecting his application for pardon
uh which is something you can do
apparently if you ask for a part and
don't get it you can sue the department
of justice
um and of course it's uh it's a good
thing that his application is being
rejected because
the guy is a psycho and a scumbag and
richly deserves to be locked in a cage
really for the rest of his life
but i think you know talking about crazy
things and
and uh things that nobody will believe
that the brief obsession we had in this
country with
tiger king and the way that this guy was
turned into a sympathetic character
somehow
we'll go down as another example of a
you know
of mass psychosis on the part of the
american public
brought on maybe by boredom and stress i
don't think it was
a coincidence that this show was so
popular at the beginning of the
lockdowns when everybody was stressed
out locked in their homes not knowing
what to do
but um and i'm not saying the show
wasn't wasn't uh
fascinating you know like a in a kind of
rubbernecking
uh an automobile crash sort of way it
was
but very obvious to me all along that
this guy is everybody in the show
every single one total scumbag all of
them should probably be in prison
and uh joe exotic will will stay there
all right
we're going to get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but
here's a a bonus not really a headline
per se
but it deserves our attention i think
and i just wanted to show you this this
is a photo that in fact i captured doing
a little bit of
journalism myself on the street as i do
sometimes
i captured this photo photo yesterday
while going into a kroger
kroger here in nashville um i was
getting some smoked sausage to make uh
what proved to be a rather delicious
sausage and potato cajun stir-fry but
anyway that's
neither here nor there the point is this
what you can see here in the photo
if you're watching the show if you're
not i'll describe it
it's a shopping cart that someone is
ditched
in the parking lot which i've made very
clear
i mean throughout my career this is
something i've talked about
often the problem of people ditching
shopping carts in the parking lot but
here's what makes this so infuriating to
me
um it's that this is worse than just the
normal
degenerates and narrative wells who will
leave their carts just in the middle of
you know in the middle of the lot
somewhere wherever they wherever they
unload it they'll just leave it there
and then they'll drive away
that's bad enough but in this case
someone has brought the cart
back to the cart corral almost
all the way but left it five feet
from the corral partially in someone's
parking spot
rather than simply pushing it like
literally another five feet is all you
had to do
in order to actually put it into its
proper receptacle area but they couldn't
be bothered to do that they could go
they could go
most of the way but they couldn't they
couldn't finish it off and so they just
left it there
this is uh this is a huge problem
as i've as i've argued many times
um we i think you
we we can tell we we know everything we
need to know about you
all of your your your character
can be summarized by what you do with a
shopping cart
when nobody is watching because it's
such a simple little thing
there's it's it's a a little thing but
requires so
little effort that if you just leave it
there
it shows you care not at all about your
fellow man
and you know when you're leaving the
shopping cart gust of wind
could easily pick that thing up
especially with the weather we've been
having gust of wind could easily come
along pick that pick it up and
send it into someone's door you know
it's not gonna be serious damage but you
know
you're leaving it here it could damage
someone else's car in order to avoid
that
all you have to do is take to stick 20
seconds to put it away
you cannot be bothered to take 20
seconds to spare someone else
damage to their property
it is outrageous morally abominable
and unconstitutional i say
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know one thing i think we can admit
as as men is that we we don't like going
to the doctors
um and we can be too embarrassed to go
we just not feel like going you know it
feels like too much of a hassle
and that's why one of our new sponsors
on the show i'm excited about
for hims.com and they're all about men's
wellness if you need help with ed if you
need help with hair loss if you have a
cold i mean anything if you're
interested in
mental health or cova 19 home kits
whatever it is that you're looking for
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats
ed this is real science real solutions
to ed hims makes it easy
hims connects you with a licensed
medical professional online who you can
prescribe who can prescribe you fda
approved prescription medication
to treat ed get the same active
ingredients as that expensive little
pill but without the expensive price tag
on top of it
and look there's no embarrassing
conversations no expensive appointments
you just answer a few questions online
and your medical you know they talk
about your medical history and then a
provider
will confidentially review everything if
approved your medication
is shipped directly to your door in
discrete packaging and shipping is free
so there's no more searching online for
answers to questions about ed or sexual
wellness
just go to your hymns account and ask a
medical professional that you can trust
try hymns today by starting out with a
free online visit go
to forhims.com matt for your free visit
that's for him.com
matt f o r h i m s dot com slash matt
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate see website for full details
and safety information remember that's
forehands.com
matt now on on monday
so this is coming up just in a couple
days december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw will
be available exclusively at
dailywire.com
this was originally an audio podcast
maybe you listened to it then
even if you did listen to it i would
recommend watching
the video version on daily wire apple tv
or roku app or at dailywire.com
and if you haven't seen it at all or
listen to it at all then you're really
in for a treat for your first time
dramatically inspiring story of course
apollo 11 what we saw is a fantastic
series
if you're looking for something for
something to watch over the holidays
with your family this is a
great educational thing i know it's for
me as a parent with
four kids we're always looking for you
know something we can watch that's
that's educational that will keep the
kids attention
right now get it for 20 off with code
watch when you become an insider or
above member over at dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to download our
apple tv or roku app
to get all of our content on your big
screen and also on monday i don't want
to put too much on your plate but also
on monday be sure to watch
backstage at 7 pm central time to see
all the daily wire hosts
ramping up the year i'll be there as
well you know it's you're not really
tuning in for that but i will i will be
there
and uh that should be a good time so
make sure to tune in for that as well
again dailywire.com subscribe for apollo
11 what we saw
now let's get to our daily cancellation
so today for our cancellation i want to
briefly revisit the conversation we had
yesterday to start the show about
prostitution and pornography especially
the kind
you find on sites like only fans many
prominent voices on the left including
aoc and
the aclu and many others have recently
been promoting prostitution in
particular
cyber prostitution as real work sex work
is real work they say
now i made the case that if a woman
getting paid to take off her clothes on
camera is doing real work
which i don't think she is but if she is
it's certainly a very different kind of
work
from the type performed by members of
legitimate and noble professions
the prostitute is selling her dignity
for profit she is debasing herself for
the enjoyment of strangers it is a
shameful dirty
bad way to make a living and it should
not be normalized or mainstreamed or
promoted
now the first thing to realize about my
point on this subject is that it is
completely
obvious and nearly everyone in the world
would have agreed with it up until 12
seconds ago
i have and this happens to me a lot i've
received a hell of a lot of backlash for
saying something that
10 billion people throughout history
have already said
and that nearly everyone would have
taken for granted as a simple
and incontrovertible fact it has never
been
easier to be controversial to be a
provocateur
all you have to do is say stuff like
it's not good to be a prostitute or
men don't menstruate and suddenly you
become edgy
you're edgy now for saying that when in
reality you're saying the least
edgy things a person could possibly say
but the left has been so successful in
their war on reality and on common sense
and on basic human decency and morality
that even people who are not on the left
now suddenly
are treating these common sense
propositions as controversial
if not outright unspeakable
um with all that said i have one other
point i wanted to make in relation to
this topic
and i hesitate to make it only because i
fear that i might be giving my critics
too much credit
with this argument that i will present
um i'm not sure if i i hope i'm not
giving them too much credit but the
point is this
if you're a parent and you're also among
the people who have gotten angry at me
for saying that prostitution and
pornography are shameful and debasing
industries
and that neither women nor men should be
involved in it
and then it's bad for for for it's it's
bad for everybody involved
if you disagree and again if you're a
parent yourself
then why don't you want your own
daughter to be a prostitute or a porn
star
now like i said i may be giving you too
much credit it's possible that you're
even more depraved than i anticipate
but my guess is that for all of your
talk about the validity and nobility and
empowerment of prostitution
you have not ever and would not ever
encourage your daughter to grow up and
become
one you have not and would not look at a
little seven-year-old girl in your home
who you love and wish to protect and
think to yourself
i really hope she sets up an only fans
account when she's old enough
i'm guessing and certainly hoping that
you have never ever
ever had that thought and never would
have it
but why i mean you say it's empowering
and liberating for women to do this you
say it's noble it's good
why don't you want your daughter to do
this empowering liberating thing
don't you want her to be liberated you
know it's also empowering and liberating
to be a mother a doctor a scientist a
business owner an artist
and you probably would be quite happy
for your daughter to become any one of
those things wouldn't you
in fact you may even actively want them
to become one of those things or
something similar
and if you notice as your child grows
older that she has a proclivity for
science or medicine or art
you would start guiding her in a certain
direction so that she can one day have a
career in those fields
yet as your child grows older and she
spends time on social media
if she starts acting inappropriately
there you would never in a million years
upon finding out about that say to your
daughter you know you might have a great
future as a prostitute
why why wouldn't you say that
you're saying this is a good thing yet
you wouldn't want your child to do it
that's strange isn't it so again i ask
why
well i know why of course um you don't
want your daughter in this life because
it's a shameful degrading life
and women who do it are prone to become
drug addicts and to kill themselves
in fact a great many prostitutes as
studies have repeatedly shown have a
history of being sexually abused too
that's what's all that is what propels
people to get into this line of work
a history of abuse and neglect you know
that porn and prostitution
are things that damaged people do and if
your child
ends up doing it it means that they are
damaged you don't want your child to be
damaged
you don't want her to to make a living
as masturbation fodder for creeps on the
internet
or glorified sex toys for guys they meet
in motel rooms
you don't want that for her i hope you
don't want it because you love your
child
i would suggest this if there is
something
that you wouldn't ever want anyone you
love
to ever do then you shouldn't want
anyone to do it
now there are other things a parent
might be apprehensive about their son
joining the military for fear of his
safety but
they would still be proud that he joined
right
neither heart would swell with pride
when he when he went off to basic
training
would your heart swell with pride the
first time your daughter goes to have
sex with a customer in his car
would your eyes well up with tears of
happiness upon hearing that your
daughter earned her first subscriber on
only fans
no he wouldn't because you don't want
that for her
you don't because in your heart you know
that i'm
right about everything i'm saying and
you're wrong
and that's why you don't want it for her
but you do want it for other people's
kids
because you don't care about them that's
really what this comes down to
yes these these girls are degrading
themselves but you personally don't care
if they do
you might be you might even enjoy it
when they do
because you don't know them and aren't
related to them and don't love them
that's your position if you're being
honest about it your position is
yes matt you're right it's degrading but
i don't care
and for that reason you're canceled
though i would invite anyone if you are
a parent and you want to prove me wrong
and you want to come out publicly and
say no i want my daughter to be a
prostitute
you go ahead and do that you go ahead
and do that prove me wrong
but i don't think you will because again
i'm right
100 and you're 100 wrong and also
canceled
and we'll leave it there for this week
on the show have a great weekend
everybody
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo valdoski
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
a nurse passes out after taking the
coronavirus vaccine a major
scientific journal abandons biology and
a major financial firm
foists woke politics on all of corporate
america
check it out on the michael knowles show